kanye west back on twitter is the gift
that keeps on giving Plus how pink
really feels about being named the most
beautiful hey I'm Danny direct though
this is the daily Denny and boy do we
have a hump day treat for you
you know Kanye West revived his Twitter
and it is giving me life he's straight
up dropping nuggets of wisdom as only
eases can in 280 characters or less the
rapper told fans this is his book he's
writing in real time free of any
barriers from publishers or publicist he
says it's not for money he just needs to
express himself and let me tell you
express myself he did and we're breaking
it all down here's a look at Kanye's
guide for what to do and what not to do
according to his recent tweets alright
for starters do tell the truth he says
just stop lying about just stop lying
also don't be afraid fear often causes
people to be manipulative do stay
focused
distraction is the enemy of vision don't
be competitive I don't believe in the
concept of an enemy stop looking for
something to be and just be he also says
do stay true to yourself don't follow
crowds follow the innate feelings inside
of you do what you feel not what you
think and don't start your day online
when you first wake up don't hop on the
phone or the internet or even speak to
anyone for even up to an hour if
possible just be still and enjoy your
own imagination it's better than any
movie do what you love follow your own
vision base your actions on love do
things you love and if you don't
absolutely love something stop doing it
as soon as you can and also don't be
trendy trend is always late yo and I
thought Oprah was the tree wisdom like I
hear you and see you Kanye and I am
taking notes but what does Kanye's wife
Kim Kardashian think of his guide to
life well when the Grammy winner tweeted
quote sometimes you have to get rid of
everything Kim poked fun by responding
wait
everything this started a hilarious
exchange between Kim and PAL Chrissy
Teigen who offered her and the kids a
place to stay tweeting I have an air
match
here and have been itching to busted out
if you need Kim just not clear on what
everything really means I need clarity
thanks for being such a good friend
maybe John can call and inquire but
maybe he means friends too this is
confusing Chrissy you're right we are
all screwed I still have the bouncy
house from Saturday it's a bed and a
house in one now for anyone who doesn't
have a sense of humor by the way Kim did
tweet she was just joking
it's a rest easy but can we add Kim and
Kristi slumber party in a bounce house
to my bucket list thank you right
meanwhile another amazing celeb mama was
just named People Magazine's Most
Beautiful their cover girl is pink
here's the mom of two on the cover with
her six-year-old daughter Willow and 15
month-old son
Jameson we talked about what a little
scene stealer that guy is blows face our
pink told Ellen she laughed out loud
when she found out she was on the cover
and inside the mag the Grammy winner
says she never knows if anything she's
doing is working when it comes to
parenting but I thought it's been the
most humbling thing for her ever well
one thing's for sure her little girl
willow is a firecracker just like her
badass mom as we found out firsthand
it's not very impressed by me which I
like we hear you right you can do it
yourself why would you be impressed
[Laughter]
hey that's willow just keepin it real
like her mom and I gotta say I have
always been here for Pink's brass
attitude and especially how refreshingly
honest she is about her marriage to
Carey Hart 12 years married and they've
never held anything back at least in
front of et's cameras Kari y'all earned
each other oh I know oh my good and bad
I know when you say things like that to
him I know exactly where his head goes
and I want to smack him in public but
he's a good man he is any super cute you
said it in an article you don't hand
your your wedding ring back I haven't so
much really longer time I feel like
we've come a long way this is why I used
to throw it I think I threw it in the
pool once I was doing I was standing on
top of a grotto saying to all of his
friends
never see you again have a nice oh yeah
very um yeah it's a lot very lots of
drama I mean but then you guys have made
this incredible family yeah a good dad
and you I was gonna saying you probably
look back and you're like how we did
this yeah yeah yeah I believe in the
work I believe in it
you hear that Chloe and Tristan y'all
got some work to do and you know what so
do I if I'm being honest oh I'm getting
out of here until then you guys you're
subscribed et's YouTube channel right
but not get on it because daily Deni is
going live tomorrow at 12 p.m. Pacific 3
p.m. Eastern I'll see you guys then